bankrupt, as in zero dollars in his bank
account. That's what this business owner
just approached me with. That's going to
happen within weeks, not months or
years, weeks. [music] And he's going to
have to sink his entire life savings
into it just to keep it going to the end
of the year. And so, I'm going to sit
down with Paul to help him fix his
adventure park that he's already sunk
$22 million in, which is absolutely
[music] insane. And I'm going to give
you a step-by-step road map on exactly
what he needs to do to fix the business.
And we're going to check back in with
him 90 days from now to see, A, is he
still alive? And B, did the business
[music] get fixed? But most importantly
for you if you're a business owner, I've
scaled 10 businesses to $10 million in
revenue, $3 to $100 million plus. And I
think the biggest lesson I've learned in
this entire process is the tactics and
principles that apply to this business
apply [music] to many businesses because
businesses behave in patterns. So with
that being said, let's dive into the
business. What's happening everybody?
>> What's up Paul? You ready?
>> Oh, I'm born ready. All right. So tell
me about the business.
>> Yeah. Uh my name is Paul Fontinelli, uh
founder of Boulder Adventure Park. We
are an indoor family entertainment
center in Grand Prairie, Texas. The
story actually started 8 years ago.
Okay. Uh I dreamed it up. I was working
in corporate America. Kind of [music]
uninspired at the time. Wanted to do
something entrepreneurial. I have three
young kids. Wanted to get out of that
and build a business. And
>> how much did you raise?
>> Uh raised eight. Uh total cost is 22
[music] million.
Did you put the rest in?
>> Uh I put Well, raised eight. The rest
was debt.
>> Got it. Who paid for the debt?
>> Uh bank.
>> Oh
>> Yeah.
>> It's a big loan.
>> It is a big loan and that's part of what
we're going to talk about today.
>> Yeah. No. Yeah, we will. All right. So,
uh, how does this thing
>> make money?
>> So, we're 4.8. We're not profitable yet.
That's one of our biggest challenges is
is the profitability of it. Uh, our goal
is to get to 10 million revenue over the
next few years. Uh, but what's really
the goal, what we need to talk about
today is the next 90 days. Um, so I'll
come back to that, but that's a really
big piece of kind of what we're doing
today. Uh, streams of revenue. This is
the money slide, literally. um general
admission $3246 per person with another
$11 of in park spend. They add on
arcade, food and beverage, merchandise,
you name it. Uh this makes up about 70%
of total revenue. Then then we have a
bunch of other groups in terms of church
groups, social groups, etc. And then we
literally just launched our summer camp
uh campaign today. I assume one of the
biggest things Alex is going to help
help me work on is data and metrics. I'm
not crystal clear on at the moment.
>> This is the uh take my medicine slide.
>> Yeah.
>> I own this. I don't make excuses. The
numbers that your team was asking help
me prepare and realize where some of our
deficiencies are.
>> Yeah. It's really interesting for you
because from a from a business
perspective. Um it's like you're looking
at outputs, not inputs.
>> Yeah.
>> So these numbers are inputs that create
the outputs that you're accustomed to
tracking because the core economic
arbitrage of the business is LTV CAC,
right? like that's the that's the core
arbitrage that we that we expand out and
then we just do it to infinity uh so we
actually start making a profit. Okay. So
problems the bad is we are demand
constrained right but the good news is
we can 10x the opportunity the capacity
is absolutely there as you can see peak
day is running at 50% of capacity but
emissions are down we've had struggles
with marketing conversion rates all of
that is really been one of our
challenges uh and here's the final
sandwich we are cash constraint since
opening we've we've struggled and
honestly the hardest day was when my CFO
sends me a cash flow we're not going to
make it to today. Like we were that
short and it was like do I give up? And
it was like no,
sorry. But I went home that night and I
said, man, I'm not going to make it. The
cash is not there. We won't even make it
to this show.
[snorts]
And that's when I said, "It's all in." I
looked at my 401k and I was like,
put it put it all in because that's it's
the only way. Like everybody's telling
me don't do it.
But if I'm going to go out, I want to go
all the way out. Like it's all in. I
mean, this show is [music] once in a
lifetime opportunity to sit down with
the greatest business mind of our
generation in my opinion. I mean, it's
it's priceless. I'm at the point now I'm
putting my 401k in. Um, which I believe
in this business. I believe in the
upside. I believe in this opportunity.
Um, and so it's I'm all in. Which
actually leads me to the next slide.
This literally hit me yesterday, dude.
And I was like, heard, you come, you
fight for your life. You said it
earlier. There's we have nine lives,
right? Like I might be towards the end,
but I'm here and I believe in it and I
know we've got the upside to uh to make
it happen.
>> We've got 14 days, right?
>> Yep. Exactly. [sighs]
>> God.
>> Deep breath. That's how I feel.
>> I know. Yeah. I uh feel for you.
>> No, I appreciate it.
>> Um the issues, there's so much going on.
>> Absolutely.
>> I promise I'm going to do my absolute
best to try and help.
>> I know you will.
>> So, let me ask the other question, which
is what's your monthly nut that you need
to make to break even?
>> Well, let's see. Extra.
>> Yeah. Um we need to probably be at
550,000 a month.
>> And you're at now what?
>> Uh 400.
>> Okay. So, you need 150. What is What's
the debt service right now? Monthly.
monthly, uh, it's going to be probably
about 180,000.
>> Got it. So, I'll tell you what I like
what I wrote down. So, the first thing
that we probably have to do is generate
cash.
>> And so, what I want to do is sell
basically the baddest offer that we
could possibly imagine for a season pass
to the list.
>> Okay.
>> And that's because like if we don't do
this, there won't be a season for them
to come home to. So, we need to we need
to generate uh some cash. Um,
>> may I suggest one idea to think uh our
summer camps is a huge opportunity to
drive significant cash in a very short
period of time because the window that
malls are booking summers is right now.
>> So we're May, June, July, August. So
those are kind of the four months ahead.
Key,
>> right? But then it goes into the slow
season.
>> Slow season. Yes.
>> Right. So we need to do more than just
good during this time period.
>> So we've got 600,000 extra that this has
to make just to get us to the bad
season.
>> Right.
>> Correct. How big is the team? Sales
team.
>> Sales team right now is uh three people.
>> Okay. Cuz if we have, let's say we have
this month, if we if we were to announce
tomorrow basically, cuz that's that's
the time zone we're in. I'm going to bet
average tickets be like 1,200 bucks.
>> That's where our third offer was for
$2,000. You can come any week, anytime.
>> Oh, so you could do 5 days a week, the
whole summer for two grand.
>> Correct. That was
>> so basically buy four, get 10.
>> Yep. That was meant to be the grand slam
offer.
>> That is compelling. Okay. So,
>> and that way mom or dad could just drop
their kid off any day, any time.
>> Yep.
>> So, let's say that the average ticket is
121,200, 1300. So, if it's $1,200 is the
average ticket and they can close 15 of
those a day, we're looking at uh 126,000
a day, something like that. Y
>> So, that would get us an extra
>> 450 grand. That's not enough.
>> Well, the demand for summer is
automatically going to boost revenue. I
was optimistically shooting for about
200,000 in summer camps and that would
have been a win. If you and I can dial
that in and get, you know, even close to
what you're saying,
>> it's going to put us in a strong
position. I do like the summer angle cuz
I think people will spend a lot of money
for their kids because if we if we
decide that this is the offer, right,
then we'll drive the whole email list
here. I mean, honestly, you just need to
hammer the list because it's now or
never, right?
>> We have to hammer the list. I think we
take as much of that cash as we possibly
can and we drive that back into ads.
>> Love it. And then again, feed it
through.
>> I love it.
>> So, I want to get still a little bit
clear on the summer camp offer cuz we
have kind of one shot at getting it
right.
>> Yep.
>> So, current is 300 for * 3. 3 days per
week.
>> Exactly. 500 * 5.
>> Yeah.
>> 2,000 any day.
>> And that's for the whole summer.
>> Correct.
>> I'm going to pull the uh the funnel up.
>> This looks nice. tried to follow your
>> No, it looks
>> recommendations.
>> It looks good. I like this. I like that.
>> That's cool. My big fear as a parent
would be uh is my kid going to fall and
die? That's pretty big.
>> Safety is our number one.
>> Yeah. No, I think if if we can
accommodate that, this should probably
drop off the page.
>> This kind of header.
>> Okay.
>> Because uh it's
>> not adding any value,
>> right? It's the most valuable real
estate on here. Okay.
>> We also have like four banners. So we
have this banner, we have this banner,
we have this banner, and we have this
banner.
>> Yep.
>> We want to have basically one banner. So
it's like what's the most important
thing? I think this is probably the most
important thing.
>> Yeah,
>> cuz we want to let we want to know let
them know the times. I think this can
>> we can get rid of this this thing. This
is basically a repeating of this.
>> Yeah.
>> So I get rid of both of these.
>> Um I would put this Google review stuff.
So you already have it here. So, I think
you probably can just nyx it. I do like
this little edge. Basically, you want to
put trust right next to the action.
>> So, you have this parent rating right
around the button. So, that feels okay.
>> Y
>> um I want to put something around
injury. So, like do you know how many
like hospital visits? I I just want to
show an obvious stat which is like last
year zero falls.
>> I would just put that cuz that's what I
want to know. Okay, that's good. I like
that. Um day one money back if you Okay,
that's really good cuz that's obviously
like what if he doesn't like it?
Whatever. Yeah, exactly.
>> That's good. See, this is these are the
reviews. It's like I'd rather have that
than the than this one. Got it. It's
like it's also relevant to the specific
>> Yep.
>> uh thing. That's good.
>> And we are going to be recording a VSSL.
>> Yeah. I was like the only thing I think
it needs is a video. Um
>> where would you put it?
>> Uh probably right at the top.
>> Okay.
>> So, it' be like headline
>> thing and then um and then I would just
cut all this
>> cuz it looks like too much text. It's
like
>> that's the main part. Makes perfect
sense. So those are the funnel tweaks
that I would make on the actual page. So
it's been 90 days. I think it's way more
interesting to see what actually
happened. So let's check back in with
Paul.
>> All right. So the next thing Alex taught
me was how to clean up the landing page.
And what we found out by far the best
thing on that page was the VSSL. There's
a reason Alex talks about the VSSL. The
VSSL helped a ton. We even used the VSSL
to put it into ads and it was our best
converting ads. Well, good. I'm glad
that worked. That's how that's how that
works. Give them more information and
people want to buy more. Now, let's talk
about like how we're going to drive
traffic to that offer. So, we have the
the brick and mortar. So, these are the
flows and like I'm only focusing on one
thing because you don't have
>> the luxury of time.
>> Sure.
>> And so, you basically we basically need
to make one bet. The season pass was my
original guess, but I think summer is
going to make more sense.
>> Yep.
>> So, that's what we're going to run.
Okay.
>> Um Okay. So we have our email list.
>> Yep.
>> As our sources of traffic. Number two,
uh we have our attach
general
admission attach rates.
We can do that.
>> What do you mean by attach rates?
>> The motion.
>> Okay.
>> I can say motion easier.
Um and then we have our paid ads
direct. Okay. So if this is these are
kind of our four call it our four flows
that are going to run
>> into this beautiful right.
>> Yep.
>> So on the paid ads I'm going to say a
unspeakable
uh video clips.
>> Okay.
>> As probably the first primary way of of
the actual creative for the ads.
>> Okay. Um, B is we want to have the
offer, which I would experiment with.
Buy four, get 10 weeks free or get six
weeks free.
>> Okay.
>> And that might destroy. So,
>> yeah, it's [laughter] good.
>> Um, yeah, buy four, get six is pretty
solid. Um, I like that a lot. That's
pretty good. I would also So, 2,000
divided by 10 is 200. So, as low
as 200 per week. Okay.
>> As another angle.
>> Yep.
>> Um I'm thinking about different front
end.
>> All right.
So if we're going to the front end. All
right.
So we have a buy XKY free offer. Yep.
>> Right. As a version of that,
>> we have a um this is kind of the early
bird. So I would use early bird as an
angle. Okay.
And then just pair it. Buy four get
get six also. Buy
one month get whole summer.
>> That's a good way to say it.
>> Right.
>> These are all the things they all mean
the same thing but the one clicks.
Exactly.
>> Yeah. So this is an ear basically add
early bird to it's like why is he doing
that? Because early bird. It's like we
have to always answer the reason why
we're making an offer.
>> Got it.
>> Um so buy four get six. by one month get
whole summer buy
one month get two free.
>> Yep.
>> That's good if you want this to go
mental. But the question is like I I'm
I'm I'm only a little bit worried about
your sales team's ability to
>> actually like call all the leads. So
this would this is probably what I would
consider to be like the fundamentally
sound way of approaching this.
>> If you wanted to go ballistic, which we
might just need ballisticness,
>> I like the sound of it. Then we do do
the full summer offer, right? We'll just
call it $2,000 private summer camp.
>> Private uh summer
experience, whatever camp giveaway.
And so that means that one person that
you pick gets the whole camp for free.
This is first place. I want to have
second place be like the core offer,
which is $1,000 off. But the core offer
is this. Okay, hold on. So we can say
the value. So um if we have uh $500 a
week times 10, so it's $5,000.
>> Yes.
>> Right. So $5,000 and then we could make
this second place is $3,000 off.
>> Yep.
>> For the whole summer.
>> Okay.
>> That sounds sexy.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> And then let's run this.
>> So $5,000 value. I get that. And then
what's the 3,000 off?
>> Off the 5,000.
>> Got it.
>> So then it's the $2,000 ticket.
>> Okay. Got it.
>> Um so this is the first and second place
prize.
>> Okay. Um, make sure that you say more
than one person can win second place
just so you're, you know, legal and
compliant. By all means, I'm not an
attorney. Run this bag of attorneys,
blah blah blah blah. Um, yeah, you're
responsible for your own decisions. And,
you know, these results may vary in
financial performance, etc. Okay.
Uh, but more than one winner, but at the
end of the day, honestly, this is going
to be the this is going to be the
humdinger if you just lead with
$5,000 private summer cramp uh full
summer experience giveaway. Y
>> second place prize wins $3,000 off.
We're offering a prize to give away
summer camp every day this summer for
[music] your entire family up to three
kids. Here's how it works. When you opt
in, you're entering to win an all summer
camp pass for your entire family up to
three kids. That means you can drop your
kids off here at [music] Boulder any day
that camp is going on whenever you
choose. This is an unbelievable offer
valued at over $20,000
for up to three kids in your [music]
family. All you have to do is opt in to
have a chance to win. Even if you don't
win, [music] everybody that opts in to
enter is going to win a scholarship
summer camp offer from Boulder so
[music] your kids can have the best
summer camp experience of their lives.
Enter for a chance to win.
>> So you just needed to use the word free.
Um otherwise the rest of this is all
really good. It's got good visuals. He's
good energy. He started with the really
expensive thing so it's anchored so they
know that it's going to be uh you know
pricey if they want to buy. Um the only
thing I would have done differently is I
wouldn't say everyone is going to win a
scholarship cuz that kind of removes the
the excitement out of winning or getting
a scholarship. So, I would have just
tweaked it so you just say more than one
person can win and you have your first
and second place prize and you should
have just said first place prize is
this, second place prize is this and
then during the 7-day countdown done the
drawing and then that's when you contact
people and say, "Hey, you got one of the
second place prizes." Tiny tweak, but it
makes a pretty big difference in
conversion. But the actual creative
itself, like the actual the the energy,
the vibe, the the camera, the like how
they showed everything really good.
Fundamentally sound because the thing is
is we have to run this fast because they
got to know if they're going to do it
right. So this is going to basically be
>> 7day like a 7 to 10 day campaign.
>> Okay.
>> After you select the winner, you then
call all these leads.
>> Yep.
>> To then sell them using the standard
offer.
>> Perfect.
>> Which is this.
>> Yep. And then uh and then the stand and
then basically you kick off the campaign
that runs to the page that you just went
to.
>> Okay.
>> And then you'll call all those leads.
Yep. So this will give you a flood of
leads. It's going to be 7 days. We're
going to cram we're going to push the
email here. We're going to push the the
paid uh the paid ads to here. Love it.
>> And then phones follow up. I'm going to
draw this out for you. So
>> we're going to have giveaway ads
>> plus page. And this is just a landing
page.
>> Those are going to be great.
>> All right. And you just want to have a
countdown timer at the top because
that's what creates the urgency around
it.
>> And then with this, just send an email
and text of how many days left until the
drawing.
>> Got it?
>> And then on that day, pick one person.
Congratulations, you won. Great.
>> And then everybody else, hey,
congratulations, you won second prize.
>> Y
>> right. And then like but then you have
to put another count for them to claim
it, which is like our summer camp's
filling up. So in order to make
otherwise they're not going to claim it.
>> Yeah. Um, you have 72 hours to claim
your claim your second place.
>> All right. So,
>> and that's what I'm sending in the
landing page.
>> Yeah. So, 7-day
countdown
and then 72 hours to claim second.
Then after that
to we fire off the buy for get six
variations that we just typed over
there. Um, and then basically you have
to run this until the cows come home,
but
>> yeah.
>> And then on the thank you page for the
giveaway,
um, make sure this is legal in your
state. So, this is not me saying this is
legal. Make sure that the laws of your
area allow this. On the thank you page,
um, have an opt-in that says, "Do you
want do you have any other parents who,
um, have kids?" Um, you can like send
them this page. Uh, so just gives them a
copyable link and then they can forward
it to a friend and for every person that
you send to opt in, you get an
additional drawing in the giveaway.
>> Brilliant. Because parents love when
their kids go with their friends kids.
>> Yeah.
>> Yep.
>> So, um, plus one referral
ticket. And so,
here we go.
>> So, you're going to give away two of
these,
>> right? So, one goes to the winner. And
if you're the person who referred the
winner, you get it too.
>> Awesome.
>> That way they can. So if you just for
yourself Yeah. If you just do it for
you, you got a shot. If you refer a 100
friends, you have 100 more chances.
>> She referred you, so she wins, too.
>> All right. Here's what I want you to do.
You call her, put me on three-way, and
then you get to tell her the good news.
>> Okay. Hold on.
>> One eternity later.
>> I called you and didn't tell you to hold
on. [laughter]
So, guess what?
>> One,
>> let's go.
>> One of the fun things about giveaways is
that like you actually do give something
away. And so, it always feels good to
just, you know, help somebody out or
help a business owner out or parent out
or whatever, whatever your business is.
So, it's one of like the nice feel goods
and you usually typically get a lot of
good um I mean, just like this, you get
a lot of good media out of it. So, it's
like you just you can't not win with
that offer. If you have the right pieces
for it, it absolutely slaps. Once we run
this whole play, then we have to flip
the campaign to this. And this offer
might have to change as the summer moves
on, but I think this becomes the call it
evergreen structure for the summer.
>> This becomes the launch.
>> And we're the the benefit of this is
that we're we're advertising the big
number. And so, when it gets dropped
down all the way to 300 bucks,
>> I love that.
>> It feels like nothing, right? And you're
attracting people who want this big
thing. And so you don't need to you
don't need to tell you don't when they
get on the phone you don't have to sell
them the big package. They already said
they wanted it.
>> I'm just this is a master at work.
You're so good at this.
>> Oh let's
>> Yeah, I know. I know. Let's get it to
work.
>> Keep going. You're doing great.
>> Um but I think this is the best shot you
have at getting the cash that you need.
>> I love it.
>> Um but that's basically this is how do
we get you through cuz it basically at
the rate you're at now you have 90 days
of burn. But if we make money, then all
of a sudden that pushes
>> and like you said, that then feeds the
next business unit,
>> right?
>> Yep.
>> There's a lot of stuff, but
>> there's only a few moves that are going
to make you the amount of money that you
need that's material.
>> The leads were coming in good. Cost per
lead was better than what we'd gotten on
any other lead we'd ever had before.
>> Yes.
Yes.
>> Things were really improving. I was
getting excited. Then because of the
7-day urgency, the timer of how long the
giveaway was doing, the last 48 hours
were crazy. Leads just started coming in
like crazy because the giveaway was
>> never giveaways or launches.
Whatever you think is going to happen,
you'll usually get somewhere between a
third and half of your leads in the last
48 hours. So if you have like a six week
long campaign, still the last 48 hours.
And every time you think, oh no, it's
not going to be like that. I promise you
it's going to be exactly like that. So,
you have to model it out because in the
middle there's this kind of stretch
where you feel like an absolute
because nothing's working because it's
just like the lead starts cost start
going up. But just like you have to keep
going on it, keep gassing it and then
you will just hit it through the through
the ceiling if that's a saying.
>> At the very end, we got 3,700
leads.
>> Mind you, this is a local market, so
that's a lot of leads. It's like 120
leads per day. Um, we'll see how he
converted them. But yeah, that's it.
>> It's brilliant.
>> Cool.
>> We'll run it.
>> The play
>> and we will execute it.
>> Alex, thank you.
>> Appreciate you, man.
>> No, I appreciate you're in a hard spot.
>> It's okay.
>> Smooth seas do not make a strong sailor
or whatever the whatever there saying
is. All right, let's uh let's look at
where we're at in the scaling road map.
How many employees do you have? A
thousand.
>> 150.
>> Yeah, this business that's so tough. How
many are like not just date workers?
>> Yeah, good. Probably about 10.
>> Okay. So, that's that's probably more.
So, you're like between these two phases
between prioritize and productize. Yeah.
>> Um, basically what we did here is
>> we're spending more on niche down
messaging, which is the new the new
offer, right?
>> We made something new to sell them,
which is the product.
>> Yeah.
>> Sales aids and materials. That's going
to be the VSSL um that we're that you're
going to put on the landing page. Yep.
By the way, if you're curious, have you
been through the scale road map before?
>> I have. Oh, yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Is it good?
>> Oh, it's brilliant.
>> Yeah. So,
>> I used it last night to prepare.
>> There we go. So, it's it's free. If
you're a business owner, you're like, I
don't know what phase I'm in. Each of
these little squares has like a huge
explanation behind it to know exactly
where you're at for your business and
how to apply it. And again, it's all
free. You can go grab it.
>> All right. So, once I finished filming
with Alex and we knew the play was
summer camp giveaways, I got to work
immediately. I went in the hallway at
ACQ's headquarter. I rolled out my piece
of paper from Alex, called my marketing
guy, Kai, and I'm like, "Let's get to
work." We started talking about it right
there, figuring out what needed to
change, what needed to be updated. He
flew with me to Vegas. So, I left ACQ,
went back to the hotel room in Vegas,
and worked all night on the changes that
needed to be made, the ads that needed
to be written, the technical updates
that had to be done. Everything had to
be done quick because in business, speed
is key.
>> Well, good. I'm glad he took action.
What we did was we just bought him if he
executes everything three more months to
live. And so sometimes a lot of
entrepreneurship is just buying the next
the next week, the next month, the next
payroll. It's tough. I mean, you got to
give it to him. There's a lot of grit
like just I mean, even at the end when
he's like, I'll put my whole life
savings into like what he saved his
whole career as a you know, the
financial field um to doing this like I
have a lot of respect for it. He may
find that this offer just absolutely
murders. I mean, it's the best shot I
can think of of how do you generate cash
ethically within this season. And so, if
we can pull out of that cash forward,
which is the whole purpose of the money
model, and that gives them a couple
different angles to hit it hit it from.
And so, like Jeff Basis talks about how
if you have uh a 10% chance at 100 to
one return, you should take that bet
every time even though you're going to
be wrong nine times out of 10. The only
element that adds an element of realty
to that is you should take that bet
every time, but most entrepreneurs go in
with only enough money to to play two
hands. And so it's like, do you still
take that bet where you actually have
only a 20% chance of winning even if
it's 100x return, but you only have two
hands worth to play. And I think that's
more realistic of like what, you know,
his particular situation is. I didn't
get to know him well enough to like I
don't know his team. I don't know if
they're they're able. I don't know of
any of that stuff, but I feel pretty
confident that that offer will work.
>> Paul, what's cooking, man?
>> Still going, brother.
>> Still going. Did you
>> still going?
>> Did you have to put your 401k in?
>> Yeah. Whole thing.
>> Oh, Jesus.
>> That's the life, right?
>> All right. So, what what what did you
do? Did you Did you run the play? Like,
what?
>> Walk me through walk me through.
>> Ran the play.
>> We got an insane amount of leads. like
so much so that it it we didn't have the
manpower to deliver what we needed to
deliver to close the leads.
>> Better than the alternative problem. I'm
only a little bit worried about your
sales team's ability.
>> We got 3,700
leads and we're trying to call these
leads. I mean, I got a minuscule sales
team, right? So, we ran the play, don't
get me wrong.
>> And and we did good. We did 325%
increase compared to prior year in
summer camps. So that's good news.
>> But it could have been so much higher if
we had the proper manpower and call
sequence and all of the STR
>> leads,
>> the true model, which is we just didn't
have it in that time.
>> I mean, I do think that is still your
grand slame offer. Uh, and if you have a
10 to1 play that you put every dollar
you put in, you get 10 back, you should
run that play a whole lot of times.
>> And so I think what we can do is like
>> probably just need to get scale up the
sales team a little bit. Um, and you can
run the same play just for birthdays.
>> Birthdays is our wheelhouse. Yeah.
>> Right. And that is
>> and year round you can run it and you
just don't need to spend 20. You can
spend two or three and then you can
scale it up. anything else that that
that we talked about that you did?
>> Yeah, I got to unspeakable. He gave us
permission to start running ads with his
videos. Yeah. Which you talked about and
they're converting strong and we've
we've been seeing that like our our
admissions has doubled um in visitation
just over the last you know four to six
weeks.
>> All right. So that is the plan. So,
giveaways for birthdays and then you
probably need to
>> bring on a couple sales people to handle
the volume. And I wouldn't be afraid of
hiring sales people cuz as long as you
have lead flow, sales people will always
make you more than the price for them.
So, like I would just don't be afraid of
that. That's that's growth spend.
>> Okay.
>> Very low risk.
>> Yeah. Sweet. Beautiful. Beautiful.
>> All right. Do you feel like do you feel
hopeful?
>> I do. the team is stronger than ever and
now with these models starting to kind
of find their way like there's
foundation being built that's stronger
than it's ever been.
>> I have a lot of heart for Paul. If I had
to give Paul one incredibly strong
compliment is that he has a really
positive attitude about everything. Many
people would be really sad and depressed
in this moment and he's like got a smile
on his face. He's got super high energy.
you know, like if you were about to lose
your business and put all your savings
in, like you would probably not be
making ads like this or have this kind
of like overall vibe. And I think
whether it's this or something else,
like I can probably say that Paul will
not give up. And if you look at a long
enough time horizon and when he's 80
plus years old and looking back, he'll
have figured it out. Is it possible for
Paul to lose if he doesn't stop? Not
really. He might change vehicles, but
he'll just keep trying. And I think that
that's probably the the biggest lesson
that any new we could take from